agent 47 went to France in March and
Italy in April and now we know when his
third mission launches I'm Tony and this
is your elusive gamespot news update
hitman episode 3 comes to ps4 xbox one
and pc on May 31st the new stage is set
in Marrakesh one of Morocco's largest
cities it's laid out with a bunch of
alleyways market stalls and cafes and
you can take to the rooftops for a
better view of the region marrakech is
hit is called the Gilded Age and as
usual you'll have two targets to
assassinate private banker Klaus
strandberg and general resid on and of
course the mission will offer plenty of
unique kill opportunities challenges and
escalation missions marrakech is the
third of six planned missions for hitman
assuming its price like the second map
sapienza you'll be able to grab it for
10 bucks and if you want the full hitman
experience you can purchase all
previously released and upcoming maps
for 60 in the meantime keep your sights
trained on gamespot for all the latest
in hitman news